all. We can definitely do better than
that.
Easy. Like our defaults probably do
better.
All right. What do we got for uh
experiments
This is just like the laggiest
crap. It's like supposed to be like the
faster wand to be and it's just laggy
crap. Like what the hell is Look at
this. It doesn't even freaking
work. Nope. He uh he wrote me a unhinged
essay that
like an unhinged essay on like
the
no like let's just say that guy is
um one of the problems with the field
and why it sucks so much for the last 10
years. And uh I had some suspicions, but
from the message like yeah. And the real
kicker is he wrote me an essay and then
he stopped replying.
But the crazy thing about it is he was
like he said stuff like you have to have
clarity on like why you know you're
doing the things you're doing or
whatever. But like basically his
description of like you know how the
field has gone and like you know what
like the improvements have been and
stuff that he had in there have been
literally the opposite of what's
actually
happened. I don't freaking
know. It's like I read that I was like,
"All right, no wonder this field doesn't
freaking
work, you
know." Okay. Okay. This is something.
This is a
2.9. This is a reasonable curve. So,
this
is
and 2.8 bill.
It would be really nice if this thing
actually
hate. I mean, okay, this is like this is
valid.
There anything I can actually like check
on this
then? I don't have I like don't have a
window open with this, do
I?
Nope. Their stuff is just
down. Well, I mean this was the fix
though.
I guess then what we do is in the
meantime we try to hunt the uh the
sweeps bug.
Yeah, we like try to hunt our sweeps
bug.
went? Here it is. Oh, maybe I do have a
neural MMO. Hang
on. Nope. Nope.
Nope.
Ah, this I actually do have. Cool.
So, this is
useful.
2.9. So, three
billish 3 million
Yeah, that's a good
result. That's very solid.
I guess the next thing is going to be I
mean when we actually run a sweep trying
to get a sweep to run with DDP
maybe so that
um we can actually sweep taking into
account distributed
uh distributed speedups.
do. But yeah, I think we have uh the
branches that we were looking for here.
AI for
AI here.
Hey, bird just came flew into the window
for no reason. Don't do that. Not smart.
I mean, they literally see me here on in
the window, so like I don't know what
they're
doing. They don't fly into them super
fast here, luckily.
We've got all sorts of nice birds here.
We've got like really really like bright
red cardinals and these like cobalt blue
uh
bluebirds. Got yellow orals. We even
have a few green hummingbirds. Very
nice. What else is around here? We've
got uh rabbits. Lots of
rabbits. The occasional
turtle. Cardinal in the window.
The Cardinals are
here? I come back to
this. Hey,
I'm looking for like other things in
here that I could have possibly
changed. Okay, here's the grid policy.
I did bet it didn't it didn't repro
properly.
No, I'm just trying to like get a sense
of what changed around this
time.
[Music]
Mhm. I should probably run a better like
attempt at repro on the
again? Okay, Neptune's back
up. So, I can actually probably go look
for the original now.
really? Oh, I guess
so. Huh?
auto. Okay. So, I mean according to
this, this
is what was run.
Oh, we actually can probably have these
uh getting darker. It gets dark, you'll
actually be able to see the tiny boxes
in the background. They're really cool.
I guess the question is going to be if
this doesn't repro, what the hell
happened, right?
Oh, that's why it was down. They were
updating the website.
I'm trying to think what else I can do
in the meantime cuz
like I need to run this experiment for a
while. Start a new M stuff.
I mean these are kind of the two crucial
things at the
moment is uh the
DDP like DDP and good sweeps are the two
key key
things. I mean, technically, I've been
putting off like just the work of uh
figuring out and exporting all the new
policies for a release. So, I could do
that. I think realistically how much
stuff there is that I I need to do like
before I can release this.
It's kind of just like
sweeps and
DDP. We have pretty much all the
baselines
done. I guess we just have to put all
the M's up still, right?
put all the new M's
up. I guess I could technically go do
some detective work on
here. It's just so weird that this is
like there's such a big change in the
sweep perf.
Okay. So this is just
change to 32
length. Okay. And this doesn't work.
And this
one fixing the
final the final
step. Okay.
merge. Okay. So then this didn't do
anything. And then this
coefficient and also the tweaks to the
breakout config.
clipping even though the sub
22nd doesn't use the clipping
colif. Guess it's faster
though. It's probably faster params like
faster
sim. What's this?
Yeah, like I don't see anything crazy
here at
all. There anything I can
do? The only other thing I don't know is
if there were any differences
in sweep
setup. There would have been
though. Don't think that there would
have been.
quick. Okay, so this is when I know that
their end was
broken. Here's the maze. The full maze
sweep really
changed? I'm going to feel really
freaking stupid if max size
change, but it
didn't. Like almost sure of it.
It's so weird that this doesn't
repro. How's the sweep
doing? Working on anything cool today?
working on uh distributed
training. We got the new hardware
in. See if you can see this in the
background. See the two white boxes up
there under the uh the stars of the
flag plus 12
GPUs. So now Puffer has 20
4090s. Quite
nice. So I uh I was working on getting
these set up
today a little bit. Working on
distributed training
setups. There are a few things.
on.
Oh yeah,
that you can see the two blocks of wood
behind me. Uh those are the packing
those were packing material for the tiny
boxes. So, George Hotz was uh kind
enough to send me some deadlift blocks
with my
order. I don't know if I call this
reproing
though. Like, it has to actually get a
run that is better than
this. You know, they actually they did a
ridiculously good job packaging that
thing. It had like three layers of like
foam corners with air
gaps. It was like a box and a box in a
box uh with like foam corners at each
layer. And then they air tagged the
whole thing that the package air tagged
loot box vibes.
Yeah, to be fair, they could
have. Things are heavy, though. It was
not easy to get them onto that rack and
like get the feet to sit correctly on
the top of the
rack. I only have one of them hooked up
so far. The other one's plugged in, but
like I need to get um it's not
connecting to the network for whatever
reason. So, I'm waiting till uh I I
ordered a VGA cable so I can plug into
it. It plugs in via VGA for some reason.
No
biggie. It's been pretty good so far
though. Like, no. This is nothing to
scoff at. 64090s.
interesting. Have you benchmarked
them? Speed is uh comparable. Well, the
single card speed is comparable to any
of these 4090s that I have already. So,
I mean, they're they're real 4090s. They
run at the speed of a 4090, which
actually, funny enough, is about the
same as the speed of an
repros, I will be able to solve this
basically. Like if this repros the
sweep, then I'll be able to solve this
issue. If this doesn't repro
though, then what the hell do I do?
What's the contingency plan for if this
doesn't reap
Yeah, but like the sweep repro [ __ ]
takes
forever. The thing is like I actually I
have a very nice log of
exactly what I was having issues with on
the last sweep
repro and uh I've done everything
correctly as far as that last study
went.
So it's like controlling the number of
steps you run for
But I'm trying to think what like what
is even the error surface, right?
Like if this doesn't repro, what what is
even the possible error surface?
I'm pretty sure this is the same machine
I ran the
uh the sweep on as
well, right? Like if I go back to find
that sweep from
before, where is
it? Where is it?
They are
vacinitted. So this
was this was from
Which is probably why I have a bunch of
sweeps that like randomly died at some
point. No, cuz this actually has the
deck ref bug back in it.
action? Oh, cuz it's just continued.
That's fine.
um 60
bill? Well, that's a really good
run. That's a really good run, isn't it?
Hold
on. Wait a
five. Oh, no. I just see five.
Okay, the five at 60 bill
is pretty decent.
compares. Going to throw the grid params
on meta.
All
right. See what this
thing. Be weird if I end up getting like
very similar
results. Although I think this is
slower if I uh recall. Yeah, this is a
fair bit slower.
It's actually a really big concern if
the sweep does still doesn't repro.
Like that would be really major,
wouldn't
it? We need those sweeps. That's like
one of the main things for the uh
results uh of the release.
The only thing I could possibly think
of, right, is that I changed some
defaults or some like sweep params.
Yeah, but like there's a difference
between there being a little bit of
variability and like the thing perfectly
solving in less than 100 experiments
versus being down 20% after
200. Not a small difference.
We also have results for multiple ends.
There's a difference for at least for
breakout and for grid for both of
Best thing I can do is just to let this
thing
differently. Okay,
ready? We'll put these guys
here the chat
up. Okay, so on the left will be the run
that
worked. On the right will be the run
that did not work.
Okay.
So you can see qualitatively right the
massive difference in these two
runs. If I go to our sample view or our
sweep progress view
here. Okay. So first of all I mean I
guess this 200 run is like split like
two different runs in here. So whatever
we'll do like this.
This finds like roughly the correct
learning rate.
Gamas
[Music]
lambdas one update
epoch learning rate way higher.
No, there's one bad sample
here and then
0001 pretty much
comparable. This one spends way more
time running
um too high learning rate though.
high. It's like a factor of two high on
the
second. Yeah, it it just generally I
think it runs it has a whole bunch of
bad runs.
But like what does this tell us about
why this error
occurs? Like update epox is one and
locked. So numbum ms is going to be
different here. But this
is like this is run with Vecnum M2 and
this one's run with a Vecnum M believe
eight. You can see the massive
difference in cost here really more than
anything. Burrito
Frontier and look like in a 100 seconds
you have these solves and this
Yeah, low cost on the second is a very
big
difference. I agree.
It could technically be something with
the mini batch size I guess here because
like this one just runs way few
experiments at the optimal mini
batch but like still this gets 87
um even with 16k and this doesn't get
anywhere
ends. Break training completely.
Team match is
892. To be fair, this was one of the
parameters that changed. So again, none
of this is going to matter if it doesn't
repro from the old branch.
Yeah, but
like what's that have to do
with I like all this is only
relevant if the original run repros,
right? Like the original sweep repros.
If the original sweep doesn't
repro, then like looking at the
difference between these two doesn't
tell us that much.
doing. We can go through the sweep code,
but like we check the diff already.
Weird. I mean, are we? Cuz like it was
working before.
change. Yeah, I did rerun. And also
um the one that we're running right now,
the repro we're running now is with the
old num like the old Beckend numbers.
Yes, the individual experiments do
reprod.
Like I can take the best run from the
old version of the code where the sweep
was good and I can train that model but
the sweep can't find those parameters.
I'm trying to think
like does the thing is it doesn't show
you deltas from the commit that you ran
the experiment on. But I'm trying to
think like if I messed with if I messed
with anything before running that
experiment.
stochastic like that logic is a trained
model is the problem.
something. I'm just like messing around
with a few
I figured I would like mix the um the
main hypers from grid with the gamma
lambda tuned for meta and see if that
does anything.
I don't think anything could have
changed within the logic for the sweep
itself either. Bet.
I was pretty sure
that I mean I guess I can go double
check one
thing, but like it still wouldn't
explain the lack of
reproing though. Admittedly, I'm not
sure that it doesn't repro yet, right?
Like these are pretty good. It could be
I just straight up didn't run this for
long enough, you
know, that this just is a slow start and
then it actually works.
I could believe
that. I mean, it would be it would make
the most sense to be honest out of
anything cuz it would be like absolutely
crazy cursed if this doesn't
repro. I mean, and then if this does
repro, I should just be able to go and
exactly match all of the hyper pram
ranges and like be less cavalier about
it and then that should just run.
outcome. I should actually probably
assume that that's the case or at least
plan for that possibly being the case.
So once I finish this one meta
experiment, I should set it up to like
run that sweep confirmation and just be
very careful about matching
params. Then that's kind of
it. I might just do that for
tonight. Then I'll have pretty much
everything up and running.
Uh, I'm currently rerunning the old
sweep and then I'll have to set the new
one up locally, I think.
better. Yeah. I know we will be able to
beat these as well because
like I suspect this doesn't correspond
to a ridiculously good policy.
It's hard to do objectively best
params. Not really a way to do
that. There's no theory behind any of
this
know. You know what I really want to
work on once we get all the RL stuff
working? I want to work on RL for
sci-fi. Like, how do we use really good
RL to just make some sci-fi
Like if you were to pick fields, right?
Not fields that like you think are super
important right now or whatever, but
like if you were to pick like what
fields need like are would actually be
the most important to making like crazy
sci-fi [ __ ] in the future. Like I don't
think it's humanoid robots for instance.
Like I actually don't think humanoid
robotics even plays that big of a role
at all. Like I think it's stuff like
materials
engineering. Um like some real hard
there. Nano particle
production. Yeah. Tyler. Hey. Hey Tyler.
Is it is it possible to make an
antimatter engine? Can we make an
antimatter fueled
engine? Like, can we do some real sci-fi
[ __ ] Is that
[Laughter]
possible? Hey, now we we actually have
the physics PhD here. We have a doctor
of physics here, so we can ask him
stupid sci-fi
Oh, a
physicist.
Like, so so in like the culture novels,
right? They've got like antimatter
fueled engines for missiles and and
spaceships and [ __ ] Can we just do
that? Make it happen. It's not that
hard, right?
Totally possible.
Yeah. So, like here's kind of one of the
things that
um one of the things that kind of amuses
me and why I'm like I think that you
know probably like 80% of these like
what if this sci-fi like they're
probably stupid but like you got to
think about it there's probably zero
people actually
good. Yeah, that author was crazy as
well. He was like a nutty, but he could
write some cool
stuff, you know, like one of the things
I
actually I really appreciated about his
stuff was he was actually kind of
self-aware. Yo uh bet did you read use
of
weapons. I really liked how he was kind
of self-aware where he had this like
ridiculously ridiculously leftist idea
of a like a a fantasy like sci-fi
utopia, but he was still like self-aware
enough to put like the you know like you
know and some people thought like maybe
some people thought that they were soft
and like they didn't punish people like
yeah so do I. that that scene from the
opening of that book was
like not only was it really good, it was
just also really self-aware in a kind of
a rare way. I thought it was pretty
cool. According to my
calculations, the flight that just dis
Wait, what? Dude, I asked you for his
physics, not conspiracy.
possible with antimatter if the spheres
were around the density of
aridium and 10 to 12 feet in
What? Wait, I thought I thought
antimatter is like you blow up a
continent if you have a gram of it or
something. Isn't that wrong? Is that
right? I thought
like isn't
it? Maybe I'm
wrong. It's like some ludicrous amount
of energy
though. Isn't it straight up like MC
squared? like literally that amount of
energy. So like whatever it's like a
kilogram is times 10 the
16th.
Yeah. So like a gram of it is is 10 the
13th jewels. Is that
it? Like one gram is like 10 the 13th
jewels.
Uh, let's see if Grock bans me for this.
Jewels, energy,
uh,
Batman.
Yeah.
So, that's like a gram of antimatter,
right?
Yeah, it's literally it's more than fat
man, right?
You know,
honestly, here's the reason I like
thinking about this stuff, even though
it's like [ __ ] crazy out there and
not what you would like not what serious
scientists spend their time thinking
about.
Also, I've got like a bunch of deer just
coming up to my window that we're gonna
going to have to get some venison steak
if they get any closer.
Um, all right. Um, but here here's the
thing. Like, this is why I actually like
thinking about these things. Like, if
you just if anybody thinks about this
for like five seconds, right? There is
no way you're getting like space fairing
travel out of sci-fi with any
conventional fuel source,
right? Like there's just no
way. You're not going to have like
massive massive tanks of like hydrogen
or oxygen like or whatever,
right? Poaching. Nah, they're on the
family farm, man. That's not
poaching. You can absolutely shoot deer
on your
farm. Yeah, but you you see what I mean?
Like there's no way, right? So
like it kind of
is it's like you've almost got nothing
to lose trying to go for these crazy out
there things because like basically zero
like there is no amount of incremental
progress on like current methods that is
going to get you like crazy sci-fi
actually let's let's do another like
comparison. Okay. I I I thought of one
more thing.
10 the
13th.
So 8 *
10. So if this is correct, right, then
the largest ever
rocket has had less energy in it than
Fat
Man, which has had less energy in it
than one gram of antimatter.
Right. 10 to the 13th sounds
high. I mean, you can double check this,
right?
Hey, Amed. How's it going? We're running
experiments and talking about random
physics stuff as well.
I honestly didn't expect this to work
out so perfectly where it's literally
like I guess it makes sense. I wouldn't
expect a rocket to have more energy in
the fuel than a freaking nuke,
right? Actually, that does sound high,
doesn't
it? Yeah, Tyler, that does sound high,
right? Like a rocket blowing up
shouldn't is not going to do anywhere
near as much damage as a nuclear weapon,
right?
Am I just totally wrong? And
like literally the rockets have gotten
so big by now that like they literally
have the fuel reserves of a nuclear
weapon
equivalent time thing
too. The light of the
bomb if they really used 2.2 2 million
kg. That's
crazy in reaction going. Yeah. Well, I'm
at the thing that So, this
discussion, it's some sci-fi
shenanigans. So, like look at
this.
The largest rocket ever has less than
six * 10 13th jewels of fuel.
Okay.
Batman. So like an old
nuke, not even one of the like the
original one really like we have bigger
ones now, but
like is there like
actually like like just based on your
background, right? like of like knowing
physics. Is there like an obvious reason
why this is batshit and like not even
worth investigating or is it just like
you know the general impression that
this type of thing is like so far out
there that like why would you like even
think about that?
Is there like, yeah, no way. It's
physically impossible because XYZ,
you're never going to actually be able
to get and like release in a controlled
fashion the energy of a gram of
antimatter. We don't have the
superconductors we need
yet. We have superconductors, don't we?
We just don't have room temperature
ones, right? Or am I dumb?
Wait, you Tyler also like the main thing
is the superconductors, they only work
when it's really cold, right? And like
it's freaking absolute zero in
Right. They saturate at high fields.
need high fields to store a lot of
energy.
Ah, that's freaking
cool. They become
nonlinear.
So,
it's you have to confine it with
magnetic
fields. Do you basically you
need is the idea just that you need
ridiculously strong magnets and the only
way to make ridiculously strong magnets
is with really good superconductors.
melting, what if the coils were in
freaking
space, right? Does that
background that helps a
little. Dr. McNab presented something
for NASA for putting an electromagnetic
launcher into a crater on the moon that
was at superconducting temps would need
to reflect the sunlight. That's freaking
cool.
right? Oh, no. Wait, cuz it's billion
versus per
kilogram. You got to put it into jewels,
dude.
6. Yeah, that's about
it at a jewel
range
is Yeah. Like my like dead reckoning
based on like no actual knowledge guess
is like if you accidentally blew up a
rocket it would level like some city
blocks and if you accidentally well if
you blew up a nuke you know it leaves
like a mile wide crater or
whatever. Where does then Saturn V? This
is
um this is the SpaceX
one is the the reference for biggest
rocket. SpaceX Starship with super heavy
pressure. I mean
it a crater is a crater, right?
Isn't that a like irrelevant bet? Cuz
like Yeah, like any explosion does that.
The bigger explosion does it more,
I mean, that's just saying it's a shock
wave, right? But like, that's literally
any any
explosive. So, like that's not that's
not like a meaningful distinction then.
Yeah.
It's not like, oh, it does more because
the type. It's cuz it releases more
energy,
right? Obviously, like ignoring the
radiation damage.
Yeah, but like I wasn't even considering
it for that, right? Like then the point
was not for weaponry. The point was like
amount of
energy. Like the amount of energy in a
nuke is enough to get you into orbit.
Literally, it's actually probably a lot
more energy than you need to get you
into orbit considering it weighs a lot
less than a ship,
right? It probably weighs way less than
the rocket as well.
So that's probably enough to get like
several of the like actual rocket
capsules, like the crew capsules into
space. 7 kg. But that's just the
plutonium. Like there's still like a big
amount of like surrounding stuff for it.
I think that they nowadays they do
actually have them that are really
small. 7k. That's crazy.
out of topic question. My guy, this
whole freaking conversation's out of
topic. I'm just having fun talking
sci-fi stuff because Tyler's around and
he actually knows physics. Do you think
PyTorch treats ops like com 2D and
basharm 2D and so on as single nodes or
they break them into elementary
ops?
Um, it depends on the operation. So like
some some operations have fused kernels
and some don't.
I would expect that com is pretty
optimized and batchorm probably
isn't. Nuclear vault on YouTube. All
right. Will
do. I don't know. One of the things I
would like to like get a sense of from
physics though, Tyler, is like what
sci-fi stuff is like obviously
physically
impossible. What is like probably
possible? We just don't know how to do
it yet. And like what is like I don't
know, maybe possible, may not be
possible, you know?
Diamond
semis on large
scale. What? I don't know what that
means. Diamond
I have a competition soon about EEG data
classification. It's like a person
looking at three circles
flashing. We should predict which circle
he's looking at now given the EEG
signal. That's
cool. That's just some supervised
learning there.
for power electronics. That is the holy
grail. But like how good like what does
it let you do, right?
Like I can tell you like the holy grail
for reinforcement learning, right? Like
what does it imply if we solve
reinforcement learning? It means that
you have a synthetic intelligence that
is able to learn like like a human would
or better um just from any form of
interaction like any form whatsoever of
interaction.
So in a sense solving RL would mean
solving intelligence itself.
Reinforcement is just one way to learn
the solving of RL right the implication
right the hypothesis is that it is a
sufficient way to
learn how do you think I can use
RL there has to be an interaction part
to it Ahmed otherwise it's just
supervised learning
We don't try to shoehorn RL into
everything. There has to be some
interactive process. I think we have to
solve intelligence first to get sci-fi
applications. Yeah. And that's like the
deep mind theory of stuff, right? Which
is why I work on this as well because
there are probably some problems that
are AI
complete. But I don't see language
models getting us
there. Honestly, more immediate term,
the problem I care most about is the
like, you know, aging and disease
problem because that buys us time to do
everything else.
complete. All right, let me actually get
this sweep running. I'm going to just be
here yakking.
I don't think there will ever be any
aging. Why
not? I mean, that seems ridiculous.
the biological process. Of course, you
can screw with it. We just don't know
how to
yet. There are literally there are
already immortal strains of cells,
right? It actually to me it seems like
it seems impossible that we can't solve
it.
I'm
biased. Yeah, but that's like super
depressing,
right? I mean, that's like such a
defeist. Like, I don't
know. I'm pretty optimistic about tech
and what tech can do for us.
Um, I honestly think like one of the
crazier beliefs I have is that I think
we're literally going to look back on
today in I don't even know how many
years, maybe not that many. We're going
to look back on today like the literal
dark ages. Like we look back on like
cavemen and or like a
Neanderthalss. Like literally, that's
going to be the difference.
I mean, any way you cut it, it's still
lame as hell,
right? It's still freaking lame as hell.
Especially like aging is lame as hell as
well. Disease is lame as
hell. Things that should just be
eradicated.
They're just tough
problems. They're not impossible though.
No one anyone from Mexico. I don't know.
I tooured
there. I went and visited them in Palo
Alto. Too much doom and
gloom. I mean, this isn't doom and
gloom. This is pretty damn techno
optimist,
right? You want doom and gloom, just
open X and open any social media or any
news app. You'll lose all faith in
humanity
instantly. But
like, is still pretty good.
They unceremoniously took my free
credits. How will Grock play
Pokemon? Dude, just start adding like ex
employees and like instead of like
posting all this cringe and [ __ ] just
be like, "Hey, like link to Grock plays
Pokemon. Like I'm trying to do, you
know, Gro, I'm trying to make Grock play
Pokemon. Can anyone hook me up with some
credits?" Making a general statement.
referring
to.
capture. Oh yeah, I saw those. Those are
freaking funny.
Honestly, at some point the captures are
just going to be
like, you know, if you get the right
answer, then you're an
AI. Transfer
learning. Yeah, I don't think anybody
actually understands transfer learning,
Jason.
I can explain transfer learning in a
like a cavalier way. That's basically
all right. Ready? This is transfer
learning. All right. This is this is the
MIT approved
uh you know PhD whatever whatever dumb
credentials way of explaining transfer
learning. Okay. This is your
train.
Okay. And then this is
like
test. So if this works then
transfer doesn't work. Okay.
And then if this is your train.
Now camera is going to start lagging
because of
um all
this. Yeah, I don't know about this this
run here if this repros or not.
I don't know what will repro if this
doesn't
Guess we have to go like
SSHN
So we are at 8.4 4 billion steps with
four mincom
prof. Yo,
Spencer, I got one of them up and
running. The other one I got to wait for
a VGA cable cuz it's the SSH default
isn't working. I got DDP running and it
seems to be doing
okay. I'm checking that
now. So, what did I say? 8.4
billion. Oh, yeah. That basically is
spot on with the original curve. Even a
little better.
So, yeah, it looks like we have uh we've
got DDP
running pretty
solid. It required some
fixes. Definitely needed some fixes. I'm
trying to figure out what's wrong with
sweep still. I uh I'm running the old
sweep like that should repro and it may
or may not be reproing. We're not sure
yet. I've got neural MMO running on four
GPUs. I've got
um a neural MMO baseline on one of the
boxes. I've got uh a sweep on latest
puffer with old
configs. And then I've got an old sweep
running with the old configs to see if
that
repros. Any questions on uh enms or
actually let me grab a drink and then I
can answer any questions on
uh on
env. Also, tiny boxes in the background.
I will show these. Don't let me forget
to switch screen.
All right, come answer whatever
about
environments. If you have questions,
Hey,
Hyper. Camera light has me super red for
some reason right
now. I think I figured out a small fix
on
resampling. Go for it. And I'm around to
discuss if you want.
Yeah, I'll hop on
disc. Discuss this and I'm going to
bed. Are you ending live or just
starting? Ending in a bit.
I've been live
since I think I was a little lazy today.
I I started a bit after 10. Yo,
maybe I started at 12 cuz I had to do
the tiny box. I don't remember. Hey,
Spencer.
Uh, by the way, your uh your stream's
only on your face right now. Thank you.
Yeah, there's nothing to show on the
screen though at now. All right.
Anyways, okay. All I have is laggy
camera because I'm running sweep on my
local box as well.
Let's go. So, I think I have Well, we'll
find out if it solves it or not, but you
know how when resampling on GPU drive,
it was like really degrading performance
pretty hardcore every time I resampled.
Yeah,
I think I'm running an experiment right
now. The problem was that the my
everything's crashing. Uh
hello. Okay. All right. That That was
weird. I might I must I must have kicked
a cable or something.
I I literally don't know. It's like
either that or I'm overloading the GPU
with the local sweeps. So, could be
that.
Hey, for damn get a life. Get me one
with you, dude. I mean, freaking
advancing like trying to advance all
this science here is a pretty
all-consuming endeavor. You're more than
welcome to come pull up and help us dev
on it so we do it faster cuz I have lots
of other science to work on after I
solve this [ __ ] in
RL. All
right. There was a a change in
resampling. Spencer, I apologize. What
were you saying? You're good.
Uh I think the problem was that it from
the beginning it wasn't getting that
diverse of a sample based on the
random being called too quickly and I
think they were basically running the
same randoms within a few milliseconds
and since the seeding of randoms based
off of time null which is based in
seconds it wasn't getting that like that
diverse of a a level. So even when you
tried to resample the same hundred which
I thought was statistically like diverse
enough I think it actually wasn't and
and that's why it was like failing. So
when I changed the the random seating to
like
the like another way of getting time but
I think you can get it in terms of like
microsconds or at least in a smaller
thing where you'd see a difference
between one process to another when
spawning them. Yeah. Um,
it was no longer hard capped at like 86%
on Perf, you know, I've actually looked
at trying to fix that before, but it's
kind of obnoxious to get the time in
microsconds, right?
Yeah. So, I didn't do it. So, good call.
I don't know if it's going to will fully
solve it, right?
But I have a new sweep going. It's going
to take like a day, right? Cuz it's like
slow. Um, you know, we might want to
just integrate that into endbinding
where like we pass a seed in and we make
puffer like default give you like time
ns or something.
Yeah, there there's something you could
do there.
Oh, I another seating thing. Seating was
also breaking DDP.
Oh, really? Yeah. Seating all the
because it was seating all the workers
the same. breaking DDP. Yeah. The reason
why I found that was a problem for
seeding was because when I was doing
terraform experiments, the pllin what
was it? The I was trying to give it a
random seed with pear and noise and
weird somewhere in the sweep it was
spawning levels that started at 25%
completion
which meant that there was some
percentage of the grouping of levels
that were identical.
Yeah, that makes sense.
And so I applied that solution and then
I'm running that. I did a bunch of small
things to um
Terraform. I added an observation
because we didn't have an observation to
see its own
load. And I added a legal action small
penalty. I changed a little bit of how
um the delta observation map, you know,
like the second channel of the the conve
is
done.
And and then I added a instead of doing
teleportitis via random, I made it if
teleportitis if you're if you're stuck
for a certain period of time.
But if they're all like if they're all
like mosh pit in the corner, I that's
the one concern there.
What do you mean? If they're all like
doing like donuts or whatever in like a
little like corner of the map, like
stuff can happen like that where it's
just like
I like I do that in neural MMO because
like agents can just group up.
Teleportitis is a pretty good hack for
that.
Maybe I just need to play with the
uh the frequency of it then.
Yeah, but I mean if it works in real
MMO, I guess it probably could work.
Well, the thing that's a little tricky
with it is um depending on how you treat
your episodes, it can like
cap your score or whatever
uh during train time. So like it's a
little tricky to
configure. Um let's see if there's
anything else that I was trying to get
out. I mean hopefully these sweeps just
work. I'm run the current experiment I'm
running on Terraform is instead of doing
plland noise to pear and noise
um I'm doing pear and noise to random
map of either zero or two on
height and seeing if it can figure that
out. Next. The dilation's going to mess
with you. I turned off dilation to one
because the scoop is one.
Can try it. It's tough because they
can't see very far at all. Then
yeah, I mean, they can't see very far,
but I mean I also constricted the map a
little
bit. And then I changed the reward scale
to one because it's only picking up one
dirt. But I mean, I'm sweeping reward
skill, so we'll see what it finds. Yeah.
And then I dropped dozer capacity
because it was abusing rewards by just
picking up everything without ever
putting anything down.
Uh I'd already dropped dozer capacity a
ton. It was at like 200 earlier. Yeah,
it was at 5,000 before, man. All right.
Well, I made it 10 because it only picks
up one at a time. Yeah, that's real
small,
though. That's like act that's smaller
than the actual bucket is going to be.
Well, it's all relative,
right?
Yeah. Have
any
anything
here? I still don't know what the hell's
wrong with the sweeps, man. Like, I'm
hoping this I'm hoping this repros.
So like not
this. I've got these. This
is so so far there's 76 runs in here.
Okay. Like a better maybe. So this is
this is the branch that Oh yeah, my bad.
So this is the branch in which um I ran
the old good maze sweep. It got like
98%.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
You know, actually, this might be
correct cuz I'm looking at this thing
and this thing is running longer
experiments already than the current
sweeps do.
Maybe this is just like I wake up in the
morning, this repros, and then the other
one is just like, okay, figure out what
specific hyper prim like sweep settings
it was that was screwing you
up. That would be
ideal. And then it'll be
on GPU drive stuff.
No, it's default config stuff. Ah, once
I fix this, it'll fix everything.
Yeah, it's hard to say. I'm facing Yeah,
I'm facing the same issue at the moment.
Hopefully it can be figured out the next
I'm working on it. I got actually
working, right? What's that? You haven't
touched sweep code? Yeah,
like not for like a while. No, I
haven't. I checked. I cleaned up some
like minor debug stuff in there. zero
change to the actual logic. Um, it's
mostly the default the default sweet
parameter ranges have changed a bit.
Yeah,
So, I'm thinking I want to do so I got
to like things I got to do for release,
right? like top priority is get sweeps
working because that's just required for
everything. Uh DDP is a required thing
in this release as well cuz I promised a
client that it would be included. Um and
also DDP is just good to have. So we'll
have that in. Uh I got to like you know
get all the end baselines, get all the
demos for the site and then we can just
ship the Rio pretty much set. Um it's
been set. It's just been needing the
final experiments like always drag. And
then after that, I've got like a couple
things to do on meta, but otherwise
like I think building some industry
sims. Like terraform is definitely one.
Um GPU drive stuff is another. I'm
thinking we should do some sort of like
drone stuff just
because it would be so freaking easy
with like this warming capabilities we
have. It would be so
easy. Yeah, I don't think there's any
issue with that. I don't Especially
after seeing target. I mean, ideally,
I'm trying to get GPU drive into 3.0.
Yeah,
I'm just like at war with resampling for
like the past like two weeks. Well, I
think what we should do is we should
take some of these things that you're
discovering and like try to make them
harder to screw up. Like we should
probably get seating to be like if you
just use the end of binding seating,
you'll just never have that bug. Stuff
like that.
Yeah, I need to think about some of like
the small things I I change here and
there to make things work and see if
those could be helpful in other
environments
cuz there's only so many things that can
go wrong. I feel I feel like this point
I have so much confidence in the RL that
it's just like something else must be
wrong. Well, it's just like I still
break [ __ ] every so often. like when the
sweeps go wrong, that takes confidence
and stuff, right? Like there's still
things that need to be tested and
whatnot. It's overall pretty damn good.
Yeah, I'd agree. I'd agree.
Yeah. So I think next experiments I mean
I I think also I want to do like a
puffer drive postGPU drive on like a
large scale map.
I think we still have that. Um I haven't
heard back from that guy because I know
he's back from his trip in Europe but um
I think that's something that still
probably worth some attention. Yeah. And
any of those could be goodiz things.
and then I'll let you know how my
conversation goes with the factory
people tomorrow.
Yeah, could definitely other than that I
mean I think on Terraform I don't think
I have too many questions. I mean, right
now it's just seeing if this random uh
see if this experiment on solving if it
can figure out random twos or zeros on
the map and do reasonably well. And if
it does, then I'll try doing that with
the pearl and noise to pearl and
noise. Other than that, I mean, I've
considered putting dilate as a
hyperparameter.
Could do. And I've considered adding a
channel of the posi of if you if there's
an agent within the same uh radius of
its
vision. That might slow Perf a little
bit, but it's only I mean I don't in
reality I don't think we're ever going
to
have like 1,000 dozers.
That's what you think.
Well, if you do it would have to be like
a grid channel, dude, right?
Are they not like a grid already?
They're not technically going to add it
as another channel to the conf.
Yeah, that's how you do it. You would
have to loop over all the dozer. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I I was trying to find any
other way of doing it beyond that, but I
think I'm stuck with that approach at
the moment. I think do that for now
because everything else is more
obnoxious. Like, that's going to be the
mixed recontinuous grid [ __ ] thing.
And I don't think it's that bad. Like I
said, as long as I don't put in a
thousand dozers in there, then it's not
the end of the world. I mean, it can
loop over something like 15 times. It's
It shouldn't break anything too crazy. I
might go for like a
login B or like an N login thing. Oh,
not an login. A login thing um with like
drone drone stuff soon. Anyways, I might
end up making us like a nice piece that
we can use for that
for what exactly in terms of making
because just like discretizing I don't
want to have to discretize [ __ ] into
like 3D cubes.
I just want to have like an way of
getting
nearby entities.
Oh, yeah. That's still um up in the air
as to how to do that. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, the grid thing is not bad, but
it is um like the odds. It's not bad,
but I mean, it's not super fast either.
I mean, um at least in I feel like I did
like a pretty decent job of making it
fast, but it's not I feel like I'm more
just like it's not amazing, right? Well,
actually, I think that you can make the
logic for like updating it in the end
code, you can do that millions, no
problem. Um yeah I mean I think the only
reason it's not mega fast in GPU drive
is the whole observation like being size
like 4,000. Yes. So that like the thing
is it does add bandwidth and also coms
are
like coms are just not that fast of an
architecture. It turns out they're not.
Yeah.
Like
honestly, if whenever we can get away
with it, doing like linear into LSTM or
like MLP into LSTM gets us 2 million
step per second training with uh like 2
mil
permps, right?
Which is
like no, we could end up literally doing
10 mil step per second training with a
512 hidden
dim on a on a box. Pretty big.
That's only
like I think Dota like the Dota model is
a 4096 hidden dim. Yeah, it was. But do
they not have any coms?
Oh, they have a whole bunch of fancy
like sub subnet encoders though. Yeah, I
think they might have had a couple like
map obs. I forget.
But even then, I mean, their encoders
weren't that crazy. Their encoders were
incredibly crazy.
This has just been like totally simple,
right? Their
encod tossed in like regular features in
there. Spencer, do was easy. Go look at
the It's probably like one of the most
ridiculous neural nets I've ever seen.
So, like, yeah, go look up the Open AI5
architecture real quick. Let's dance
something.
Well, I thought we went over this one
day and you were like, it's conceptually
simple. It's encoders are like not the
end of the world. Just like it's not the
end of the world in the sense that like
it's like like you can see very easily
how you would put them together for any
given problem based on the data
types. But it still makes a huge mess of
the network and it's very hard to make
that run fast.
Well, was Dota fast or did they just
drop like
ungodly amounts of compute on top of it?
They dropped a thousand GPUs on it,
right? Oh, also let's see how what we
need to do to beat the Dota
record. That's the thing we can do now.
What? In terms of like steps versus like
total steps per hour or
whatever. So, two million frames every
two seconds.
Oh, that's like a million frames per
second, right? Hang on.
Oh, well, I mean, we just know we're
faster than that because we we process
more than two a million F uh SPS. So,
they just they did 1 million SPS for two
months with a rerun. As long as your
frame equals your Yeah. So, literally
like two month. That's like literally
all we have to do is we run on one box
like neural MMO 3. We run on one box for
a week and we take that record.
Yeah. For a week or two months?
uh one multiGPU box for like two weeks
a week or two. Yo, what's
up? How's it going? What's good? What's
Gucci? And what's up,
Linky? Is Is Dota still as popular as it
was? I think people still play Dota. is
definitely nowhere near as popular as it
was, but I think there's still like a
loyal community like versus League. How
is it doing? League's way more popular
in terms of popularity. Oh, by the way,
I actually Yo, uh Spencer, I thought of
something that we could do if we wanted
to try go back and uh see if we can get
Riot interested.
Something that would be way easier than
like full MOA is we could make like a
really good laning sim.
There you go. Just laning in terms of uh
like what like the actual hero laning or
the champ laning or creep laning. Creep
laning. Creep laning versus like uh RL
like enemy. So it's like a micro
practice thing and just get like really
yes an enemy.
So you could why not just solve that
with a just a
hard-coded last hitter bot
because it's really freaking hard to do
that.
Is it really? Yes. Incredibly.
That's not an easy problem. You start
you start to get you start to get a
bunch of lower health. Yeah. That's No,
you're also the enemy is freaking
hitting you. Yeah. Yeah. Well, you're
managing your health as well. You're
trading like health for last hits and
stuff.
Yeah. Yeah. What brand is your
microwave?
What? What question is this, my guy? Are
you saying I'm cooked? I'll I'll answer
this. I could tell you. I have a I have
a [ __ ] microwave. Thank you for
asking.
Just saying.
I'm on the trash.
And Spencer, not not impressed. Okay.
The ability item and modifier encoders
are not that big a deal. It's it's they
concat some stats. Throw full fully
connected. I'm assuming that's what FC
means. No
freeing fully connected.
So the unit stats I don't think are that
big a deal. But then they do what
appears to be another
round based on
I guess they're enemy their enemy
heroes. The max pool slicing is like a
little gross. That's kind of it. Like
that's kind of like an early
multi-headed attention kind of a vibe.
It it kind of feels like attention.
Yeah. And that unit attention keys thing
is a pain as well. I've did that with
neural MMO
before. that I have no idea what that
is, but yeah, I had to do that in my
PhD. It was jank.
Does it actually do anything? Yes. Yes,
it does.
Doesn't work. So, I understand like what
max pooling does, but how does
like processing something through like a
fully connected to max pooling and then
I guess drop a relu or something after
that uh cause it to like give attention
vibes? Like is it just you like
essentially the max and then no no no
it's totally different with images
versus with what we use it for in RL
man. So like it's max over entities like
think that you have like 10 units that
you can look at instead of feeding them
into a big flat layer where like you
don't know what order which one is in
and like you have to learn for all
possible orders. You just you pass each
one through the same layer independently
and then you max over the result. So
it's basically you get like an embedding
for each entity independently and then
you take a max element wise. So that
actually gives you like that operation
is mathematically identical no matter
what order you put them in. That's the
key.
Okay. I'm speaking from like deep diving
max pooling I don't know like five
months ago when I was reading Bow's
architecture in Pokemon
how many parameters did this model have
168 million
okay with the exception of unit
attention keys
It's easy to read, but could I have come
up with this? Probably not. It's This
thing's super dense. Yeah, this is
literally the best. Like, this is the
best RL like result in the field in RL.
I am not seeing any coms though.
Uh I forget whether they had any in the
final version. They might have had like
some map embedding
stuff. How is Tiny Box? I have one of
them uh set up already and the other one
I need to get VGA cable to set up
correctly. But
um I have it running distributed
training on neural MMO right now and uh
we're going to see how that goes
overnight. You're definitely going to
have to order V VGA cables because last
time I had to look for one. Like they
don't even sell them at Walmart. Radio
Shack's no longer a thing. Like
through Amazon just to get one. That's
so funny that you assume I would
actually try to go somewhere to get one.
It'll show up in a day or
two. Like that.
That's so funny, dude. I don't know when
the last time I've like gone out to buy
something versus just ordering it
is. Like I straight up don't remember.
I am paranoid and I do not do online
shopping very often
because I Yeah, I just don't like
putting my card information out there
on Amazon,
on anywhere. I don't care how secure you
think anything is, it's not. Aren't you
not even liable for fraud?
Uh, it doesn't matter. I don't want to
go through the whole rigma roll of
calling my bank and marking everything
as fraud and then having to cancel the
card because my bank is out of state and
then having to get another one sent to
me.
Okay,
Joseph, what were you thinking of
wanting to do on the the drone side of
things with with like swarm behavior?
pick my current end, make it 3D to start
with, match some dynamics a bit better,
add like a penalty for crashing into
[ __ ] and then change the task from like
go to gold to like, I don't know, some
stuff you might want drones to do.
Isn't drone RL like something they teach
in school nowadays where it's like some
of the basic concepts is to make a drone
hover close to like some fixture and
it's supposed to like track how close it
is to that. No, they do not teach you
that in school. I'm going to say
confidently I was not taught that in
school. Yeah, they don't teach that [ __ ]
in school, man.
I only say that because I perused the
reinforcement learning thing on Reddit
and I've seen probably like
it's it's probably like the fifth or so
most common post I see and I can only
assume it comes from like schooling or
something because you see like stock
exchange RL and then you get like the
basic questions on like why does DQN
suck and then Somebody comes in and
they're like, "Ah, well, I'm trying to
get a pole to stand up." And then
another guy's like, "Ah, my class is
like, "Hey, get a drone to hover as
close as you can to this object."
Uh, send them all over to Puffer Lib so
they don't have to suffer. Don't suffer.
Use Puffer.
I do. Anytime anyone brings up PO, I'm
like, "Hey, go look at this. Go look at
Puffer." You've actually been name
dropped quite a few times in that in
that.
The funny thing is like you guys I like
I stream all the time. Like if you want
to come do some RL stuff, you can
literally just come hang out. I
literally tell them it's like dude like
you can literally just come out. You can
just come hang out and build [ __ ]
Yeah, people bring up neural MMO often.
Like guys, I'm right freaking here. They
said it was They said it was in their
top 10 papers that they actually like.
Yo, link me that post. Link me that
post. I'll DM the guy.
Well, do
Oh, Joseph, one more end question on
Terraform.
Yeah. What do you think about So I
switched it back to fixed resetting and
I mean it expands fairly well to you
know go from wherever it stopped and you
just turn off you know the resets and
let it eval for a
while but it has a hard time doing
like final details.
Is that something that we should handle
through a more complex reset like you
originally did with based off of, you
know, continuous reward progress or do
we just like fine-tune it with smaller
with certain groupings of environments
where like you only have to modify two
things? It needs to learn to close out
the end without like forgetting how to
do stuff because it's not getting reward
anymore is the tricky thing.
Um I mean
ultimately if you have a metric that is
like percent of n
terraformed right?
Yeah that's what I have. If you like get
that sort of a metric
going and like the sweep just gets
closer and closer to that you'll see it
do more of the
details. The other thing is like we
might not even have to solve that
problem. We might just be able to like,
you know, like when they drive over
thing, it like smooths it cuz it's a
bulldozer,
right? Yeah. I mean, right now we're
kind of using a bulldozer as like all
forms of construction vehicles because
it's like grabbing things from like the
top of a mountain.
Well,
[Music]
um she slope cuz it can't actually go up
a mountain.
There's a maximum delta because of the
step height or whatever. Yeah, there's a
max delta.
Uh, I am actually looking for it right
now.
That's always fun.
Yeah, I'll send you a link as soon as I
find it. It's kind of funny that like
people don't realize like when they see
a cool thing like half the time you can
just message the guy and be like, "Yo, I
like this thing. Like, can we talk about
your stuff?" And most of the time people
be like, "Yeah,
cool." All right, I think I'm going to
head out. I'll let you know how sweeps
go tomorrow morning. All right, I'm
going to bed soon. I'm just making sure
things are reasonable. And I'm going to
get sleep as
well. They have an old
day. They're just fiddling with
experiments. Welcome, droid.
This is the sketch thing. Is it like
leveling before
7? Like technically this has already
gotten a little bit above 7, but not
much. I hope there wasn't some like jank
end change.
right, that's all my stuff handled.
Um, I'm going to call it and get some
sleep.
We have some folks on Twitch. So, yeah,
for the folks watching dev
Thanks for dropping by. Got a ton of
experiments
running. I'm hoping that tomorrow we'll
just have the sweep stuff fixed, the DTP
stuff fixed, and we'll be able to like
cue all our experiment up. We'll fix
some stuff on meta. We'll fix a few
other things. We'll do terraform stuff,
all that. And uh yeah, we should
actually be able to ship this thing
quite soon.
the experiments always drag on. So
like it's fine. I've already started on
like new stuff with Terraform and
whatnot like post 300. Anyways, if any
of you are developing environments, get
them PR so that they get into 3. And uh
if you would like to be developing
environments, it's all open
source. All things of
puffer.ai start the GitHub to help us
out for free really helps. Want to get
involved with dev? join the discord
whether you are already an RL guru or if
you're just looking to learn taught new
people we've uh brought in existing
people it's a good
time is dev behind 30 yeah go 30 is just
like I made the release branch because
otherwise I have to change all the links
in the new docs so yeah that's it's just
use 3
um 3 is going to be the branch that just
gets swapped to the main
one anyways
So yeah, join Discord and other than
that, you can follow me on X for more RL
content where
uh I don't know what the heck this
highlights thing is posting, but there's
RL content
here. All right, I'm gonna get some
sleep. I will be back first thing in the
morning with more
dev night.